Traductor: Marly Jáuregui
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Fue uno de los conquistadores
más temibles que han existido,
librando una imparable conquista
por todo el continente euroasiático.
Pero, ¿Genghis Khan fue
un bárbaro despiadado
o un unificador que allanó el camino
para el mundo moderno?
Lo veremos en:
"La historia vs. Genghis Khan".
"Orden, orden.
¿Quién es el acusado hoy?
¡Khan!"
"Su señoría, veo que está familiarizado
con Genghis Khan,
el conquistador del Siglo XII,
cuya campaña militar mató a millones
y no dejó nada más que una
estela de destrucción".
"Objeción. Primero que nada
se pronuncia Genghis Khan".
"¿De verdad?"
"Si, en Mongolia.
Además fue uno de los más grandes
líderes en la historia de la humanidad.
Nacido Temüjin, quedó huérfano
e indigente cuando era niño
pero superó constantes conflictos para
unificar los clanes guerreros de Mongolia
y forjó el más grande imperio
que el mundo ha visto,
al final se extendió desde
el Pacífico hasta Europa Central".
"¿Qué hay de grandioso
en la invasión y la matanza?
El norte de China perdió
2/3 de su población".
"La dinastía Jin fue hostigada
por las tribus del norte,
les pagó para pelear entre ellas
y periódicamente las atacaba.
Genghis Khan no estaba dispuesto
a sufrir el mismo destino
que el último Khan que trató
de unificar a los Mongoles,
y el cambio demográfico reflejaría
un pobre mantenimiento del censo,
sin mencionar que muchos campesinos
eran llevados al ejército de Khan".
"Puedes analizar todos los
números que desees,
pero ellos aniquilaron ciudades
enteras y a todos sus habitantes".
"El Khan prefería enemigos que
se rendían y pagaban tributos,
y creía firmemente en la lealtad
y la ley diplomática.
Las ciudades masacradas eran las que
se rebelaban después de rendirse,
o asesinadas como embajadores.
Lo suyo fue un entendimiento
estricto de la justicia".
"Muchos relatos cuentan que la brutalidad
de su ejército excedía la justicia
arrancando bebés del
vientre de sus madres,
usando prisioneros como
escudos humanos,
o como relleno de fosos para
sostener máquinas de asedio,
tomando a todas las mujeres
de los pueblos conquistados..."
"¡Suficiente! ¡Qué salvaje!"
"¿Realmente es mucho peor que
otros ejércitos medievales?"
"No es excusa para las
atrocidades de Genghis Khan".
"Pero hace de Genghis Khan
algo excepcional para su tiempo
más que un salvaje sediento de sangre.
De hecho, después de su unificación con
las tribus abolió el rapto de las novias,
a las mujeres de la nobleza
les iba mejor que a la mayoría.
Controlaban los asuntos domésticos,
podían divorciarse de sus esposos,
y eran consejeras de confianza.
Temüjin permaneció con
su primera esposa toda su vida,
incluso crió como propio
a su posible hijo ilegítimo".
"De todas formas, el legado de
Genghis Khan fue un desastre:
40 millones de muertos en Eurasia durante
las conquistas de sus descendientes.
El 10 % de la población mundial.
Sin incluir las muertes por la Peste Negra
llevadas a Europa por la Horda de Oro
después del asedio a Kaffa".
"Seguramente no fue intencional".
"En realidad, cuando vieron morir
a sus tropas por la Peste,
catapultaron los cuerpos infectados
encima de las murallas de la ciudad".
"¡Puaj!"
"Los relatos a los que se refiere
fueron escritos más de 100 años
después de los hechos.
¿Qué tan confiables crees que son?
Los sobrevivientes cosecharon los frutos
del imperio que fundó Genghis Khan".
"¿Frutos?"
"El Imperio Mongol practicó la tolerancia
religiosa entre todas las personas,
trataban bien a sus soldados, eran
ascendidos por méritos, no por linaje,
establecieron un amplio sistema postal,
y fortalecieron el estado de derecho,
sin mencionar su
contribución a la cultura".
"¿Te refieres a la forma en que
Hulagu Khan exterminó Bagdad,
la capital cultural de la época?
¿Bibliotecas, hospitales y palacios
quemados, canales de riego enterrados?
"Bagdad fue desafortunada,
porque el califa se negó a rendirse,
y luego Berke Khan castigó a Hulagu
por la destrucción desmedida.
No era política de Mongolia
destruir la cultura.
Usualmente salvaban médicos, sabios,
y artesanos de los lugares conquistados,
y los llevaban por el reino,
difundiendo sus
conocimientos por el mundo".
"¿Qué me dice de la
devastación de Kievan Rus,
que dejó a su gente en la Edad Oscura
incluso cuando el Renacimiento
proliferaba en el oeste de Europa".
"El oeste de Europa era apenas
pacífico en ese tiempo.
La estabilidad de la ley mongola hizo
florecer la Ruta de la Seda una vez más,
permitiendo el comercio y el intercambio
cultural entre el este y el oeste,
y su legado llevó a Rusia y China
de principados violentos
a estados unificados.
De hecho, mucho después del Imperio,
se pueden hallar descendientes
de Genghis Khan
entre la nobleza de toda Eurasia.
"No sorprendería que un tirano
inspire a más tiranos".
"Ten cuidado de cómo lo llamas.
Podrías estar emparentado".
"¿Qué?"
"Hoy, hay 16 millones de hombres
descendientes de Genghis Khan.
Esto es, uno de cada 200".
Por cada gran conquistador,
hay millones de conquistados.
¿Cuál de estas historia sobrevivirá?
¿Podrá el significado histórico
o cultural de un líder
pesar más que las muertes
que provocó en su camino?
Estas son las preguntas que surgen
cuando llevamos a la historia a juicio.